I consider myself a New Yorker.
I was born in the Great State of New
Jersey at Perth Amboy,
general hospital,
but got out of Highland Park,
New Jersey to go to boarding school at
age 12.
I knew there was a bigger and better
way.
A lot of us from New Jersey,
you have a complex about being from New
Jersey,
but I have written myself of that
complex because they all have to come
from somewhere and sometimes our
somewheres maybe seemed like nowhere,
but that nowhere gets us to somewhere
and it makes us be better.
So I'm proud to be a jersey boy,
but you're making an assumption that
Jersey
symbolizes something and I don't know
what that assumption is.
Let's just say that
I wanted to make things and be something
and try to create things.
And where I came from had nothing to do
with stopping or starting the.
I just wanted to do something was driven
home by my parents.